- Good evening.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
For some of you, can you
just raise your hand?
Is this your first event
as part of this weekend?
Okay, welcome, welcome, welcome.
Part of my responsibility
for welcoming you
and my pleasure in welcoming
you to this part of the event
is to let you understand
how this all evolved.
Please know that the people
on the event committee,
led so ably by Eve Hart Rice,
so ably by Eve Hart Rice,
never felt that this was the culmination
of acknowledging the first women.
This is the launch of
acknowledging first woman.
(applause)
This evening, this weekend,
started almost four years ago
at the lunch table of Marta Moret.
She brought together, for whatever reason,
a number of women.
It was a small group,
but included was Eve Rice
from the class of '73, Connie
Royster from the class of '72.
(applause)
I was there from the class of '71.
Linda Lorimer was there
as being a pivotal person
involved and interested in
what's happening with women
and what's happening
across the university.
And a number of other people
kind of came in and out
with some of those
meetings, but it started
almost four years ago as
we were talking about women
at Yale, what's happening now,
what happened in the past,
how do we acknowledge our past?
How does that get infused, and
transferred, and documented,
and encouraged among the
women who are here now?
How have we gone out into the world?
How did we get here?
And in that process, as
we talked about women
across Yale, and realized
upcoming was the 150th anniversary
of women at the university
because the first ones came in
1869, and those of us who came
to the college came in 1969,
we wanted to do things that would really
put in perspective what did we face.
We know that there were
women who came before us
who had it harder than we did.
What happened to those women
who came when there was only
one woman here at the law school?
Or only two people at the graduate school?
Or only maybe one person
at the medical school?
We know they had a difficult time.
And so, we are not here to
diminish anything that they went
through, or however
they handled themselves,
or what the university was like then,
but we know that even women
who came to the college,
maybe in 1967, or even 1980,
may have had a difficult time.
It's not to diminish that.
But one of the things
we felt truly was that
the women who came when we
did had a unique experience.
It took having a critical
mass coming at the same time
specifically to the college
that changed the life
of every woman at this university.
It meant a push for more faculty,
it meant a push for more administrators,
it meant a push for all kinds of things.
And in this conversation, we
acknowledge that there were men
in our classes, and who preceded us
who helped to make this happen.
We do not diminish that at all.
And we knew that there
were men who came with us,
who really are our staunch allies.
But the key thing that we
kept saying to ourselves is,
many of us never knew each
other when we were here.
We were spread out across
the 12 residential colleges.
And even the women who
came and were at Vanderbilt
were not necessarily
encouraged to meet together,
and it's not as though
we wanted to be isolated
from anybody in this room who was really
one of our staunch allies.
But we felt that this
was our pivotal chance
to encourage, invite, acknowledge,
and see all around us the
women we had never met before,
or who only saw for a few
times on campus 50 years ago,
but had never kept in touch with.
And so that's why the focus
was to have the core women
who came in 1969,
whether we stayed or not,
the pivotal thing was to keep saying,
what would bring us together,
what would acknowledge,
what would make people
feel safe, protected,
feel like they want to tell their stories.
We wanted to document it in the way
that might be best for everybody.
And we know that some people
have come back to reunions,
and we're glad of that.
And that we have heard there are people
who've never stepped foot in Yale again.
So, we would rather err on the
side of repeating something
that maybe some people
saw before or heard before
so that the people who never came back
felt that they had a unifying experience
and that they were
understanding and seeing
what has changed at Yale, how
you made an impact at Yale,
what your legacy is here at Yale.
So, having said those things,
I try to at least acknowledge
to those of you who may have felt left out
why we did what we did, how
we came to be here right now,
and to welcome you to
understanding why we admire you,
we respect you, but we felt
that we needed to have time
to meet with one another.
So that, in some of the sessions
that are really closed to
anybody other than the people
from 1969, please understand,
it's that we felt that there
needed to be some times
when we looked to the right,
when we looked to the left,
maybe we didn't know those women then,
but they were part of the sisterhood
that was here at a critical
time in Yale's history.
And that is the emphasis of this weekend.
(applause)
That's why.
So, welcome, welcome, welcome,
and it's my pleasure to salute all of us
by having a toast and asking
the president of Yale to come forward.
Now, most of you have
heard his stellar resume,
and there's actually a glass
up here for you, Peter.
Most of you have heard her stellar resume,
and you know the long version
of all of his accolades.
He is a man who has been
here who came to do his PhD
and he met his wife at that point in time.
They have been here on
the university campus
where he is now the Chris
Argyris Professor of Psychology.
He has played a role as
being not only a professor,
but chair of his department,
and the dean of the graduate school,
the dean of the college, the provost.
And he may be the 23rd president of Yale,
but my favorite introduction to him
is he is the man who is smart
enough, confident enough,
and lucky enough to be
married to Marta Moret,
Peter Salovey.
(applause)
- Vera, that was great.
- And here's your wine.
- All right, thank you.
Vera, thank you.
That was an amazing
introduction, I have to say.
One that I loved, and Marta
loved even more, I think.
Well, look at yourselves, this
is an amazing, amazing group.
I can't tell you how thrilling
it is for Marta and for me
to be here with you, and to
welcome you back to campus.
It is a pleasure, it's an honor,
it's humbling, but it's also fantastic.
And thank you, thank you for coming back.
You know, Marta and I
have another privilege,
which is people thanked us
when we were greeting people
as they came in the door, you all,
and people saying, "Thank you
for putting this on for us."
And we didn't put it on for you.
I just am lucky enough to
work with a group of people
who are willing to labor
hard in putting wonderful,
wonderful tributes, wonderful events,
wonderful commemorations together
on behalf of this university.
And the truth is, Marta got to say that,
at that night that Vera was talking about,
"Let's have a celebration."
And the next thing you know,
volunteers and Yale staff
are working together to make it happen.
And I just get to say, "Thank
you" to all those people
who pulled this weekend together.
To Eve, to Linda, and to
all the committee people,
too many to mention by name,
thank you for what you did.
What people are telling
me is that they're having
the time of their life,
they're delighted to be back,
and that makes us all so so grateful.
So, what a milestone.
50 years since coeducation at Yale.
And in our panel after dinner,
we'll hear more about how that happened.
But you all changed campus forever.
You all, that is right, give
yourself a round of applause.
(applause)
I know you've been doing
that all day, but ...
Yale is an immeasurably
better place in 2019,
than it was, certainly, in 1701,
because of what you did in 1969.
And we are thankful for that.
We are pleased to welcome so
many of you back to campus,
and we are especially gratified
to hear about your experiences,
whether we're speaking
one-on-one or as part of a panel.
Thank you for sharing all of that with us.
So as we commemorate 50 years,
we salute the classes of
1970, 1971, 1972, 1973, there was no 1970,
one, two, and three, I got a
little ahead of myself there.
We wish there had been a
1970, but '71, '72, and '73.
Your courage, your determination
inspire us and inspire
every member of the Yale community.
So let's raise a glass to the
trailblazers of coeducation
in Yale College to all
the remarkable women
who have made Yale what it is today.
Cheers.
(applause)
- It had been my pleasure 10 years ago
with my classmate Susan
Yisis, who some of you know,
to, on behalf of the class of 1971
to host a luncheon celebrating
40 years of coeducation.
We got pushed back on that,
but we did it anyway at
the Yale Club in New York.
And that brought together,
it's my understanding for the first time
in about 20 to 25 years,
John Wilkinson, who was here
and we saw this morning,
Sam, who's, I've met for the first time
10 years ago, unfortunately.
But also, the person who--
(laughter)
- Well, I feel the same way! (laughs)
- They don't have to take that.
When I say "unfortunately",
that was my first time meeting him.
And, you know, I'm pleased
that I met him then,
but it's like, what took me so long?
How did it take so long
for me to meet him?
But now, he can't get rid
of me, what can I say?
- That's good.
- And so, he was the one I did not know,
but the other person who
was at that luncheon,
whom I had met because she
interviewed me for Yale,
and because I worked for her in this ...
With her in the summer of
1973, was Elga Wasserman.
And I think Diana Wasserman
is still in the room.
Diana, are you still here?
(applause)
I know, and ...
Now, that was, to me,
was the pivotal group
that made coeducation happen.
And it was ...
We heard the stories
about how things happened,
and we heard how we were selected,
and these are the people who
are just so important to us.
And as we were involving John Wilkinson
and other people about
this particular weekend,
I was a little bit hard
for us to convince Sam
that he should be talking to us again.
Because he's talked to us
at the cluster reunion,
he's talked to different reunion classes,
it's like what would make this different?
And what he was willing to
do was to do a fireside chat.
He was willing and he
specifically would be honored
to be interviewed by Margaret Warner.
So you heard the longer introduction
from Margaret this morning,
you know that she had worked
for PBS for a number of years,
you know that she's involved
with the Jackson Institute,
so I'm gonna get off the stage
to just introduce the person
who we've really come to hear,
and that is the key person with Elga
who made coeducation happen for us,
who was the assistant working
with Kingman Brewster,
who was the secretary of the university,
and who has been so involved
with many aspects of Yale.
And he is the voice of authority
about how we came into being
here at Yale and is our inspiration.
So, do I make up for that?
- Thank you, dear.
- Thank you.
(laughter)
- If I believe that.
- So great to be here, though.
Sam, aren't you disappointed
there's not a fire?
(laughter)
- Well, I'm, I'm a little,
yeah, I am disappointed,
but I hope there's not
a fire in the building.
(laughter)
- Yeah, I do, I do, I agree.
Well, Vera, thank you so much,
and friends I've been with really remarked
on how well-produced this has been.
I mean, I'm looking at some key people
and I don't know how you pulled it off.
It's really fantastic.
So to you.
(applause)
So we're going to talk for, I don't know--
- A couple hours, three hours.
(laughter)
- I'm trying, I don't want
to tread the same ground,
because everybody was there this morning,
I assume, and this afternoon.
But Sam, you were here,
incredibly, for every event.
What did we leave out?
Was there something
significant about what happened
and how it happened that
you'd like to highlight,
that you don't think
was highlighted enough?
- The first thing I would say is that
in looking at anything historically,
I'm not an historian, but
all great historians tell me,
"You look at the context first."
What was going on around.
We had a wonderful panel this afternoon
of people who talked about,
Bev Gage was the chair,
and talked about the general context
in the United States at this time.
In the little book I
published about May Day, 1970,
I have used the phrase, "the
era of challenge to authority".
And I see this period as being a period
in which we've come out
of the Second World War,
but we have a group of aged leaders,
people who are much older.
And then all of a sudden, Jack
Kennedy was elected president
and to people my age then,
I guess I was 25, 27,
when Kennedy was elected,
it was a whole new world opening up.
The young were coming
forward, we were gonna get
new leadership in everything we did.
And then, of course, he was assassinated.
And then Martin Luther
King and Bobby Kennedy
were assassinated, and
these were our heroes,
depending on who we were and so on.
These were the great heroes.
Then, Rachel Carson comes
out with the "Silent Spring",
and "The Feminine Mystique",
and the Stonewall riots
in Greenwich Village,
and the war in Vietnam.
And all these challenges were out there,
and young people from all
over this country were saying,
"Hey wait a minute, we don't
have the right leadership.
"They don't know what
they're talking about.
"And we've got to change",
and just parenthetically,
one of the things Kingman
Brewster said to me
in this period was, "You know, Sam,
"it's gonna be interesting to see
"how many of these crazy
ideas are the gospel
"25 years from now."
Well, they all became the gospel.
I mean, virtually all of them.
So, I'd like to remember that, nationally,
this country was embroiled in a revolution
in which young people were saying,
"we are tired of old leadership,
"and we want young leadership,
"and we want this country to change."
Now then, let's look at Yale itself.
Kingman Brewster became president in 1963
when Whit Griswold died,
unhappily, of cancer.
And almost immediately,
Kingman had a wonderful way
of being on vacation whenever
something went wrong at Yale.
And he and I had a deal that one of us ...
I always said, as I
was his only assistant,
and one of us had to be here.
So all my conversations with
Kingman many of these years
were on long-distance
telephones to the Caribbean
or some place like that.
But the first protest at Yale was over.
Not a national issue, but the failure
of the philosophy
department to grant tenure
to a young man named Richard Bernstein.
And none of us had ever
even heard of a protest.
And yet, out in front of Woodbridge Hall,
people were camped all night,
faculty members with their wives
were serving dinner to the radicals,
and we were sitting
there in Woodbridge Hall
feeling a little bit
like we were under fire.
This was a period in
which Yale had terrible
labor relations, and that
was as much our fault
as it was the union's.
The union administration never
understood labor relations.
We had terrible financial problems.
Yale had a deficit for the entire
13 years of Brewster's presidency.
The endowment was not big enough,
we were trying to do too much,
Kingman was trying to improve the faculty
and pay more, but there
was no money to do it.
In 1964, Brewster invited
three very distinguished ...
Excuse me, five very
distinguished scientists,
to come to Yale and examine
the sciences at Yale.
And the answer was, in a private memo,
there were only three scientists at Yale
that are worth a damn.
- Out of how many?
- Imagine that.
That's how bad the scientists had become.
The alumni were up in arms
over a whole series of issues,
and they started an organization
called Lux Et Veritas,
which was dedicated to getting
Brewster out of office.
There were the war issues,
the civil rights issues,
and Kingman was desperately
trying to improve the faculty,
both in the sciences and other fields.
So, the era in which
you all were admitted,
there was a whole lot of
things going on outside.
And those things were both consuming
the minds and the
thoughts of young people,
but they were also the things
I've just mentioned at Yale
were consuming our lives.
So much as admitting you
was the most exciting thing that we did,
we had a whole lot of other work to do.
(laughter)
- You have opined in other
settings that a major ...
And I don't know if you
said a great university,
but changes rarely come in response
to internal pressures, but external.
Yet, today we heard about ...
That faculty were unhappy because the men
weren't as accomplished as they'd like.
And, you know, we hear
that the male students,
the undergrads, were also agitated.
But do you think your paradigm holds?
- Yes, I would still argue
that, if there had not been
a societal change coming
in the role of women,
that Yale would never
have gone coeducation,
or at least not at that time.
But the pressures of the societal change
were being felt by Princeton,
and by Yale, and by Dartmouth,
which were the only three
Ivy League institutions
that had no women involved with them.
And I think that the ...
You know, there were a couple of students,
and Lanny Davis, who
was chairman of the news
in 1966, '67, I think.
He wrote an editorial every single day,
calling us the dumbest administrators
in the entire universe, world,
because we weren't admitting women.
So he had an impact.
But I do not think that the ...
Someone said today, and it
may have been Nancy Malkiel,
that we were competitive with Princeton.
I actually don't remember being ...
Feeling competitive with Princeton.
I thought we were competitive with Harvard
because they had Radcliffe and so on.
I think the other thing that ...
The Vassar project,
which did not work out,
had gotten Yale kind of geared up.
- Mm-hm.
- So, I still think it was
more external than internal.
- Even though, so you're saying you think
that the feminist movement
was powerful enough
at that early stage to create a context
that kind of pushed--
- Yeah.
Let me tell you a wonderful story.
There was one morning when I realized
that I had scheduled an appointment
for Kingman to see the feminine ...
Who wrote "The Feminine Mystique"?
- Betty Friedan.
I'd never met Betty Friedan,
but the only appointment open
was eight o'clock in the morning.
It was clear when Ms. Friedan walked in
that she had never been up before 11:30.
(laughter)
It was also clear that
she was very unhappy
to be called at eight
o'clock in the morning
to see the president of Yale.
So, she went in and she went out,
and that was a day in which I knew
I had to recommend to the president ...
We didn't have search committees,
Peter, in those days, we just did things.
I had to recommend the first
woman master of a college,
who was Kitty Lustman,
Katherine Findling-Lustman.
So a little later in the ...
(applause)
Yeah, you're right, great woman.
A little later in the morning,
I went in to see Kingman,
and I said, "I'd like to
suggest that you appoint
"Kitty Lustman as the master
of Davenport College."
He got up, went to the
window and looked out,
nothing said, he looked out,
and he turned around, he
said, "Is she a feminist?"
(laughter)
So ... (laughs)
- Well then, this is ...
I, we really wanna hear
about Kingman Brewster
because this morning, I mean,
I wrote in my notes, mystery man.
What, you were very close to him.
I mean, we heard John Wilkinson talk about
that he was under so many pressures:
money, the alums, and so forth,
but what do you think was
really at the heart of ...
And Kurt Schmoke said
there was this committee,
committee on coeducation,
and they'd actually prepare reports
about what was missing here, there,
and hadn't been done, and
he wouldn't read them.
So, fill us in on this character.
- Kingman Brewster was born in the 1920s.
He came from a very old New
England family but not ...
People thought he was very rich.
He, actually, was not at all well to do.
Indeed, that was a problem
for him and his entire career.
But he came from an
old New England family.
His father was a ne'er-do-well man
who constantly was gonna make millions
but never quite did it.
His parents were divorced early.
His mother, Florence Valentine,
married a professor of music
at the Harvard Music School
and was an absolutely magnificent woman
way ahead of her time.
She wasn't a feminist,
but she was a feminist
in the old-world sense.
Kingman was a radical as an undergraduate.
He belonged to the
American First Movement,
which was opposed to the ...
Going into the Second World War,
and he was, he and Charles
Lindbergh were the two ...
He was the undergraduate leader
and Lindbergh was the national leader.
So, he was very radical
as an undergraduate.
He came to Yale and
graduated, and then ...
No, he came to, he went
into the service first.
No, I'm sorry, he graduated
and went into the service.
And immediately under the service,
when the country went into war,
he just did a total about-face.
Mary Louise Brewster,
born in the same era,
went to Vassar, but left to
marry him during the war time.
But she was also a trustee
advisor afterwards.
They both believed that
single-sex education
was the right way to go.
And there was no doubt
in their minds that,
from an educational point of view,
this was the right thing to do.
- What was the reasoning
of that, behind that?
- Margaret, I think, I'm not
sure I ever got to the bottom
of that, but I think
they just believed it,
almost in a sense that we brought ...
Been brought up to believe
that having a college education
is a rather good thing.
I think they just believed that
single-sex education was right.
Now, Kingman had a little
bit of the Old Blue,
you know, "Stover at
Yale", the kind of Old Blue
that this is a man's world and so on.
So, I think that was part of it,
but the second thing I wanna
say about Kingman is that
he was the quintessential pragmatic.
And I will never forget the night
after Vassar had said they
didn't wanna come, we were ...
Charles Taylor, who was
the long-time provost,
and he and I were contemporaries, really.
We both were in college in the '50s,
and we both wanted to
have real coeducation.
And Charlie and I were
sitting talking to Kingman,
and the drumbeat was going,
and I think it was Charlie who
turned to Kingman and said,
"Look, Kingman, there's
a snowball up there,
"and it's coming down the
hill, and you have a choice.
"You can get under it and
we'll never see you again,
"or you can step aside and
try to help direct it."
And the light went on with
Brewster, just like that.
And he said, "You're telling
we have to be coeducation?"
And we said, "Yes."
And he said, "Okay, let's do it."
But he was very pragmatic.
And he didn't compromise
basic ethical principles,
but he knew enough to see when
things were changing that ...
When we decided, originally,
that all the women
were going to live in one college,
and it was gonna be Trumbull College.
And he went to the meeting,
John Wilkinson referred him to it,
he went to a meeting in Trumbull College.
The only time I ever worried
about Kingman's welfare,
physical welfare, because
they'd built a stage
that was sort of, little
tiny thing like this
but it looked like it was
gonna collapse anyway.
And the students were really angry.
And he heard it all,
he listened to it all,
and as we're walking out, he said,
"I think we just got the message."
(laughter)
And so, we changed, and I
think it was a good idea.
- We, most of us or many of us
saw this film last night ...
We saw several, but
there was a terrific one
and I don't know who produced it,
I'm sorry if that person's here.
I think it might have been
made for the 1989 reunion.
In any event, a much ...
Should I say, a much younger
Mr. Chauncey is talking.
And you described, I
couldn't really take notes,
but this very, to me, strange,
attitude about the intellectual
capabilities of women that was prevalent.
You talked about that some men thought
women just weren't up to it,
to the intellectual jousting.
Tell us about that.
- I honestly don't remember
that particular movie,
so I'm not sure I can--
- No, but I mean just the subject.
- Pick up on that, well.
There were all kinds of
different people at Yale.
And, I remember a man name George Pierson.
That name will mean something to Judy
and some of the rest of you,
the great Yale historian.
George Pierson was commissioned
by first Whit Griswold and then Kingman
to create the best history
department in the United States.
This was about 1961.
And George went about doing it.
And he had two prejudices.
No women in Yale College,
and no Jewish people in Yale College.
So who were his first two hires?
John Blum, a Jewish man from MIT,
and Mary Wright, a professor
of Chinese History.
And I thought to myself,
George has been converted.
He's come around, he sees the light.
In one, one of you, maybe
someone in this room
came to see me in the first term,
and said that they had been
in George Pierson's class
and that she was one of two women,
and that George had an oust
at the beginning of this term
that there would be, it
was a 50-minute class,
and that he would talk for 35 minutes
and then we'd have discussion
and then five minutes would be assigned
for the women's point of view.
So, you had this really complex situation
of people who, on the
one hand, got the message
about what was gonna go on,
and on the other hand,
they would retreat back,
they couldn't get
themselves out of the past.
And I think maybe that's
what I was talking about
in this event, because there were so many
different points of view about
why we were taking women.
And they ranged from the admissions office
said we can't get any men
unless you admit women,
the societal pressure, business,
there were some people actually believed
that Yale had an obligation to educate
the other 50% of the populationm
and that might be a good idea.
But there was no prevailing philosophy.
This all happens so fast,
you've got to remember
that the corporation
voted in November of '68,
and Elga and I had to get everything done
by August of the next year.
The admissions, the
facilities, everything.
And so I wanted, I'm not proud of this,
but I wanna underscore the fact
there was no great underlying philosophy.
Nancy again talked about the fact
that maybe we'd kinda rushed
into this too quickly,
and the answer was we did,
and you rushed in too quickly,
and it was a good idea.
(laughter)
But, I think that was the ...
(applause)
I think the fact that you must not look
for a philosophy in this event.
It didn't exist.
A lot of people had a
lot of different reasons
why women were coming.
The great, and we'll, I know
you want to come back to this,
but the great anchor was Elga Wasserman.
Because Elga ...
(applause)
Elga had the capacity, on the one hand,
to be a damn good administrator,
and to get things done.
On the other hand, as I
said at Mory's last night,
Elga was a pioneer, and she had a vision.
And pioneers who have visions
never quite accomplish
everything they wanna get done.
But she had a vision in
which Yale would have
on the faculty, in the student body,
in the administration,
50% men and 50% women
at every level and every rank.
And that was what true coeducation meant.
To Elga, it wasn't just
admitting undergraduate women,
it was the whole damn ball game.
So, if we ever had any
philosophy that we adopted later,
it was Elga's philosophy.
And she was the one
who brought that to us.
It didn't work, we did not ...
We haven't yet quite succeeded
in achieving Elga's goal,
but I think that that's
the way it turned out.
- And did she, how did she
feel about being sidelined?
I mean, it sounds like
President Brewster doesn't,
didn't, I mean, on the one
hand, he depended on her.
She was doing half the job you were,
but this business about not
giving her a real position,
she was an assistant, what was that about?
- Well, let me tell you two things.
I'll give you an analogy,
because I think some of you
may understand it better,
and then I'll bring it back to Elga.
A lot of you have heard of Bill Coffin,
the great chaplain at the time.
And Bill was a ...
(applause)
Bill was, himself, a revolutionary
in the best sense of the word.
And passionate in his
believe about civil rights,
and the draft and the Vietnam War.
Kingman and Bill Coffin fought like tigers
day after day after
day but you could never
have found two better friends.
They fought all the time
because Bill was the idealist,
Kingman had to make the damn place run.
And so, they were clashing with each other
every day of the week, and
yet they loved each other.
Now, I won't say that Elga
and Kingman loved each other,
but they deeply respected each other.
And yet, I think that, as it turns out,
I think it's very
healthy for a university,
because anyone who's president, I mean,
this man knows better than anybody
in the world as president.
Constantly, visionaries and missionaries
are coming and saying,
"You help me get ...
"Make my thing work."
And how many dozens come in
to a president of university every year?
I don't know, but there's
a whole lot of them,
and they want money, and they want help,
and they want everything.
The president favors certain ones of those
because he or she thinks it's a good idea.
And Kingman ultimately believed
that coeducation was a good idea.
But Elga never, as Bill never did,
Elga never stopped
believing in her principle
and her goal for this institution.
And Kingman never stopped
trying to make it work.
And so, the conflict, which
is perhaps overplayed as a ...
As an angry, or I don't
think that ever existed.
Now, as to her title, that
was a very separate issue.
Elga wanted to be the associate dean
or the deputy dean of Yale College.
The dean of Yale College
did not want to be told
by the president who was going to be
his deputies or his assistants.
- And who was the dean?
- George May, professor
of French, wonderful man.
But, he would not exceed to being told
from Woodbridge Hall who
was gonna be in his office.
He felt that was his prerogative
and that he was going
to appoint the people.
And it may have been a mistake for us
to go to George and ask him
to make this appointment.
Because maybe, if he had thought it up,
it might have happened.
So, I think that's a separate issue
which gets into the politics
of how universities operate.
- So, it was not anything deeper
that came and didn't
want someone so strong?
- I happen to have actually felt,
and I talked to Elga about this,
I happened to have actually thought
she had more power as an
assistant to the president
than she would have had
as an associate dean of Yale College.
I just thoughtm in the scheme of things,
it might have been a better ...
But, her view, and I, it was ...
Based in her feeling about the
academic side, in many ways,
that being an associate dean
was a more important academic position
as opposed to being an administrator.
- So, I know other people ...
I asked this this morning,
and it got a laugh,
but I'd really like to know.
How did it happen that
even the most basic,
like having bathrooms in the classroom,
buildings, was overlooked?
(laughter)
- I have to tell you a story first.
- Stories are great.
- There was a registrar at Yale College.
His name was Ronald C. Marsh.
He graduated in the class of 1917,
and he was registrar from
1917 until God knows when.
He was in the Strathcona,
and he had 13 ladies who worked for him,
and they all sat there with
pencils, recording grades.
Ronald always wore the same attire.
Not, I mean, he changed,
got it cleaned and stuff,
but he always wore a very heavy gray suit,
this was in the year
of no air conditioning.
He wore a stiff detachable white
collar and a Yale blue tie.
One of the 13 ladies who worked
in his office was Mrs. Marsh.
We were not allowed to call her Vesta.
She used to be called Mrs. Marsh.
Ronald had on his desk
a telephone and a key.
And each day, if a lady wished
to make a telephone call,
she had to stand right next to Ronald
and make the telephone call.
And if she wanted to
go to the ladies room,
there was one in SSS
then on the eighth floor,
(laughter)
she had to take the key
from Ronald, and Ronald
only allowed them to go
once in the morning and
once in the afternoon.
- Wow.
- Bathrooms were a problem.
(laughter)
- It seems to have been.
For generations.
- We did, we worried, first,
about these sorts of things
in the places where the
women were going to live.
And make sure that those were all working.
And there was a famous story
about my wanting to take the bath,
the showers out of
Vanderbilt and put bathtubs.
because my five sisters had
said women wanted bathtubs.
And then the women said
no, leave them in there.
But it, there were so
many buildings at Yale
that we just, in the seven months
that we had to do everything else,
we did not have time, we did,
somebody went around and
looked in every place,
but we just didn't get it done.
It was too, we had too
little time to get it done.
Remember, one nice person who was here
saw me earlier, reminded me
that she lives in New York,
and she said, "You know,
to have all the permits
"to renovate your kitchen in New York City
"takes longer than we had
"in order to get all this
done for all the women."
- Charlie's remarkable.
- It's, we're guilty.
- But all of us who've done renovations
can sympathize with that.
But I want to get to
questions from the audience,
but sitting back and reflecting now,
one, how momentous do you
think it was, coeducation?
And in the sort of roster of really urgent
emergencies that you had to deal with,
where does this rank, and
please don't flatter us,
but where does that having women here
rank in what you've achieved
and the greatest legacy?
- Well, I'll start one step higher.
Many of you may know Professor Jay Gitlin
in the History Department,
who's really our,
sort of, university historian.
He's not officially that,
but he knows a lot about Yale history.
And he teaches as class that
relates to Yale history,
which I attend, and he
and I have a big argument
about when did the old
Yale become the new Yale?
And my argument is that
the period of challenge
to authority, the period
of your coming to Yale,
is the period in which the
old Yale becomes the new Yale,
because it involves
women, minority students,
it involves the period
in which the Yale faculty
recognizes that there are really good PhDs
other than Yale PhDs.
(laughter)
And we begin having men, and later women,
come from the great state universities
where they always taught women.
And so, I think this era,
and I won't pick a particular part of it,
but to say this is the time
that the old Yale became the new Yale.
As to the, sort of relative,
maybe difficult year, so on.
We worked much further ahead in planning
for the admission of minority students,
that is Arthur Howe had actually started
a program in 1956 or '57
called the ABC Program.
And we began planning.
And so, by the time a larger
group of black students came,
we'd already developed the
Afro-American Studies department,
Afro-American Cultural Center,
and so, I think that was the one
that we probably did the best job on.
I'm not saying it was a perfect job.
But I think we did the best job.
And we had magnificent students who came
in that first tranche of people.
I would rank the coeducation thing
as the second most difficult,
because we only had seven months,
but there's no doubt that
having only six weeks
to prepare for May Day
was the most difficult
of the things I was involved with.
But I will also say that
this guy learned more
from those three events
than he ever learned
in the rest of his life,
and I'd learned so many different things
about people, about human nature,
I'd learn about minority events
that never would have occurred to me
if it hadn't been for those
students beating on our door,
pushing us hard for financial
aid and those kinds of things.
And the same with all of you.
I learned an enormous amount.
I mean, I think those kind of experiences
are what really make your life,
and they were early in
my life, so I was lucky.
- So can you give us one example
that is emblematic for that?
- Yeah.
Is Shirley Daniels here?
- Yes.
- Where is she?
Shirley Daniels.
(applause)
Shirley and another minority
student, Euclid Irving,
were assigned by the
Black Student Association
to deal with me.
(laughter)
And I don't know, Shirley,
how many times ...
I recall we met Friday at, I don't know,
11 o'clock every morning
or something like that,
and, you know, I kind of
thought, "You know students,
"they won't show up after the
first couple of meetings."
Well, Shirley and Euclid were
there every single Friday.
And every single Friday, they pushed me.
About the financial, we were talking
primarily about financial aid.
I learned things that I
never would have learned.
I came from a family that
didn't have a lot of money.
I was a scholarship student at Yale,
but I was very lucky.
I came from a family that had,
but I didn't understand
the fact that, for example,
that if a minority student came here,
it was not only needing the financial aid,
but it was the loss of his or her income
to the family income that was
devastating for the family.
Well now, this is the kind of thing
I wouldn't have ever learned
if it hadn't been for Shirley and Euclid
coming after me, and I think
that was incredibly important
in my education, to see issues
that I didn't ever
encounter in my own life.
- Let's open, this is fascinating, Sam.
I could continue for quite a while,
but I know people here would
like to ask some questions.
- Are you gonna start to filter
them in case they're angry?
(laughter)
- No.
Because you sounded as if you were
incredibly adept at hanging,
at handling that sort of thing.
So, I know I ignored the
right side of the room today,
so I wanna take questions
from wherever they come,
but, yes, the lady in the red jacket.
Are there microphone?
- Are there any microphones?
Here we go.
- [Barbara] I'm Barbara
Wagner, class of '73.
We've heard a lot of talk
about Yale and Princeton
and Harvard and the Ivy League.
And I have a very good friend who went
to the University of
Virginia the next year,
the first co-educated class,
which is virtually done under court order,
and they didn't even bother
taking out the urinals
because they didn't want ...
No one wanted the women there.
I'm curious whether Yale paid, you know,
was the Ivy League oblivious to,
and I have another friend who went
to the University of North Carolina
in the first freshman class
that admitted women in 1965.
I'm curious if Yale was
following the trends
among other previously all-male schools,
or was it totally focused
on the Ivy League,
and aware of not just the
trend of coeducational schools
and faculty who taught
it, state universities,
but other schools around the country
that were starting to go coed?
- I'm a little, I'm ashamed of this answer
and I was ashamed this
morning, I guess it was,
when the panel that had Nancy
Malkiel and company on it,
some of whom are a little
critical in our planning.
(laughter)
We did not really know we were
going to be coeducational
until November of 1968.
The trustees, on the whole
were, we thought were favorable,
but there were two or three who
felt so strongly against it,
we weren't sure how the
board would actually vote.
And from that moment on,
it was like being in a
long-distance race, you know?
You just had to start running.
So, we did not do any studies or anything.
The only thing we did
that was really smart,
and I'm unable to remember her name,
someone may here remember.
There was a wonderful woman who was,
have been president of
Barnard and president of ...
Became vice chancellor of UCLA.
And I'll, maybe, her name will come to me,
but we did ask her to come and talk to us
about coeducation and some of the,
some of the ideas, and she
was wonderful and brilliant.
But we didn't do studies
or anything like that.
We just got our head down and figured out
how we were gonna get
500 women into the place,
where we're going to house them,
how are we going to make
them safe as we could,
and those issues.
So, I'm embarrassed to answer
this question that way,
but no, we did not.
- I'll go here and then there.
(audience laughing)
- Here you go, right behind you.
- No.
- Oh there, OK.
- [Caroline] So my question, whoo.
Oh, I'm Caroline Britelle.
I'm from Jonathan Edward
College class of '71.
I have a scrap book and there are actually
two letters from Yale in that scrapbook.
There's one that's in
March saying, you now have,
we're now asking you to
send additional materials.
And then there was dated
something April 19th,
the actual acceptance latter.
And so I was wondering
if you could explain
a little bit about the
process that went on
and also did you, were you overwhelmed
by the number of applications?
Were there more than you expected?
Less than you expected?
- Well, as to expect it,
we had no idea how many
applicants would be.
But remember that the decision was made
in November of 1968.
The admission of men for
that year had already begun,
and so the admissions office,
the undergraduate admissions office
was already underway
admitting a class of men.
So we made the decision,
Elga and I made the decision
that we would let them do the paperwork.
They had assembled all the documents,
sent out the printed materials and so on.
But that she and I would do the whole
admissions process ourselves.
So I'm not sure, but I think
we got 11,000 aplicants,
but I'm not 100% sure of that figure,
but I think that's what it was.
So we knew that we
couldn't get our work done
as fast as the mail team was getting,
admission of men was getting done.
So I think we send out materials,
instead of what you would do
in a normal admissions process,
if we saw something was massing,
we immediately wrote to that person
and said we didn't get
your teacher's report
or we didn't get this
or we didn't get that.
So it was a little bit
of sort of rolling along
and we make a decision that this person
was gonna get in and
we put that file aside.
I have a vivid memory of a March night,
it was a miserable night,
and I walked back to my home
with one of those great big file boxes
with nothing but admissions folders in it.
I don't know how many hundred were in it.
And I knew I had to read them
all before the next morning.
And I looked down the file,
and they all looked exactly the same.
You could see the pink form
and the blue form and the white form,
but then there was in the
middle that was very thick.
And I said to myself, that's the only one
who's gonna be interesting.
(audience laughing)
And so I put it at the very end.
Because I knew I had to stay awake,
and that one would keep me awake.
So it was a process, now,
in the, one of the panels,
they talked about the things
that Elga and I were thinking about
and the famous remark I made
that if you had four brothers, you got in.
Well, that was absolutely true.
And there was one woman
the other night who came
and there you are back there,
she had four brothers.
If you had three bothers,
you were likely to get in,
and if you had two, we
certainly looked hard.
The second thing we look for
was women who had experiences
that would toughen them up.
And that might have been being a violinist
who had achieved some
kind of national stature,
it might have been an athlete
who had achieved some kind of stature.
There was another woman
who I talked with today
who had lived for the previous two years
before applying in other countries.
So we of course had a
kind of academic cut off,
but we were mostly looking for people
'cause we knew that this was
gonna be a very difficult place
for a lot of women to come to.
And I think we avoid it,
and I hope that we didn't avoid them all,
but I think we avoided a
woman who was an only child.
(audience laughing)
Okay, apparently we did, okay.
Maybe we didn't know.
Anyway, we were reluctant to admit someone
who we thought might find the hostility
of the masculine campus
something that they couldn't deal with.
- [Krista] So, can I?
Yeah, my name is Krista
Tran, class of '71.
I'd like to ask you
about probably everyone's
most heated choke point
was Yale's obligation
to the nation to produce 1,000
future male leaders of America,
and many of us, if you ask,
this would be the number one
thing we, was a controversy.
And I would like to know what your
conversations with him about that were.
- Yeah.
To be sure everyone knows the context,
Kingman had said, and I don't remember
exactly when he first said it,
we were obligated to
educate 1,000 male leaders.
Never has a greater mistake
ever been made by a Yale president
(audience laughing)
than saying that.
And I guess we sorta knew
it pretty quickly on.
It came in part from our
fear of what the alumni
reaction would be to
the admission of women.
Because we didn't have any,
talk about not making studies,
we hadn't sort of polled the alumni
or done anything to find
out how would they feel.
We had the sense that the alumni
would be very opposed to coeducation.
That was wrong.
As John Wilkinson said this morning,
the minute a male alumnus woke up
and realized he had a daughter,
he all of a sudden thought
it was a good idea.
But having said that,
Brewster had the problem
of how to back off of it.
This was combined with our,
the way we were gonna deal with it,
was we were gonna build two
new residential colleges
on the corner of Grove and Whitney.
And we had the money and
we had the plans drawn
and we had the building,
everything torn down
in the corner and then of
course the City of New Haven
wouldn't give us the permit to build 'em.
So that pulled out the
rug out from under there.
I think, I think Kingman
knew he had made a mistake,
but I think he felt having
made the public statement
that he had to sorta back it up.
But he gently backed off,
and I can't actually remember
the exact numbers as the years go on,
but I think he was willing
to back off of that
but he didn't wanna have
to make a public statement about it.
- [Krista] Did you ever
tell him it was a mistake?
- Everybody told him it was a mistake.
(audience laughing)
No, I mean,
that's too easy to say.
When he said it, I knew
why he was saying it.
We had come out of a meeting in New York
with the Lux Et Veritas group
that were out for his scalp,
and they told us if we admitted women,
they were gonna come after us.
And so we, I would actually have to say
I went along with him when he made it.
But it was a terrible mistake.
- You said something in
review following up on that,
in the Yale alumni magazine,
new one on the stands or whatever,
that, something about speaking of context
that Kingman also was
looking at fellow Ivy leaders
who were losing their jobs.
- Yes.
- Okay, explain that a little.
- In those period, and I can't
give you all the exact dates,
Nate Pusey at Harvard,
Grayson Kirk at Columbia,
Gaylord Harnwell at Penn,
and one other, all lost their jobs
because radical movements had resulted
in terrible injury, fires, people died.
And it was felt that these individuals
were not up to the times and so on.
And Kingman was constantly
trying to wend his way between the two.
Nancy Malkiel mentioned something today
which is I think we're talking about,
and that was she mentioned that Kingman
had made a comment about the,
his belief that a Black person
could not get a fair trial
in the United States.
And the second one was his
anti Vietnam War declaration.
One of the things that
Kingman and I talked about
and Charlie Taylor enormous amount
was what is right for a
college, a university president
to talk about that's of a
public, of a national stature,
as opposed to a local university thing.
So on the fair trial, Black
person getting a fair trial,
we were going into the May Day business.
A judge, the judge in
the Bobby Seale trial
in preliminary hearings
had seen two Black men
in the back of the room
reading a newspaper.
And he had found them in contempt of court
and put them in jail.
And this just went like a spark.
And the students at Yale were enraged,
and the Black community
in New Haven was in rage.
And Kingman as a lawyer was enraged
to have seen a judge do that.
So we spent 48 hours
writing that sentence.
And then he put it in a talk
to the Yale College faculty
and allowed the Yale news to
attend the faculty meeting.
He wanted that statement out.
In the Vietnam War, he eventually made
a very strong statement
against the Vietnam War.
A lot of people don't
know that one of Kingman's
very closest friends was McGeorge Bundy,
who at that time was the
National Security Advisor
to Lyndon Johnson.
Mac Bundy was one of the
architects of the Vietnam War.
I remember two occasions
with Kingman and Mac.
One in the Caribbean and one in New Haven,
in which the shouting
match was really something
as they fought over the issue.
And I remember I said to Mac,
"You should get out of that damn place."
And he looked at me and he
said, "You're an American."
This was really bitter stuff
between people who are all friends.
We all liked each other.
But Kingman's belief was
that if the national issue
affected the student body or the faculty,
he had an obligation to speak out on it.
And that was the place he drew,
the place he drew the line.
- Which I think, I won't
ask Peter to comment,
but President Rick Levent
(?) dealt with that,
and it's, are you intellectual
leader in this country,
but where they go, where is the line?
Now there's someone over here in navy blue
who's been dying to speak, go ahead.
- This is--
- Oh no, wait.
You need to stand up--
- You need a microphone.
- And you need a microphone.
- [Audience Member] This is very trivial
and it goes back three questions.
What was the role of, what was the role
of Inky Clark in admitting women?
- When Arthur Howe resigned
as dean of admissions,
and Arthur Howe is an
under-recognized man in Yale history.
He was the one who really believed
in the admission of minority students
and started the talk and he was the one
who suggested to the New York Times
that women ought to be admitted in 1956.
And Whit Griswold had that wonderful,
called the man and said,
"Arthur, I agree with you
about admitting women,
"but don't you ever dare say it again."
- At least in public.
- In public, yeah.
He resigned in 1963 to go do,
head the American Field Service,
and came and decided that that staff
that was there was too old,
and not a modern group
of admissions people.
And so he chose Inky Clark to head it up.
Clark was carrying out what Arthur Howe
had started, in many ways.
Inky Clark was great.
He hired a magnificent
young group of people
to come in and do this thing.
He did what he was asked to do,
which was to change the face of Yale.
His great weakness was that
he had no sense of diplomacy.
And he was abrupt and straightforward.
What he said was right,
but he kinda said it
in a way that didn't,
was a little bit angry.
But he was very good because he brought
the institution from an old fashioned way
of looking at things to a modern way.
And I think Inky felt he'd done his job.
He didn't stay too long.
I can't remember the number of years,
maybe six years at the most.
And then he became headmaster
of a school somewhere.
But he was a great guy
and he was good at it
but boy, he didn't, he never
went to diplomatic school.
- No, and with the alums.
Yes, congresswoman.
- [Congresswoman] Presidents matter
and I wanted to say, Sam, that
Kingman Brewster mattered.
Thank you, Marta, very much,
and to Marta and to Peter,
it's not disrespectful, but
the tone that you've set
in 2019 makes a difference.
I just want to take this
brief moment to go back
a point or two on the question
of the African-American
students, Shirley and Euclid,
and the diligence in
which the cultural groups
made a difference and I can
pulse the push in that context.
At the reception earlier
we were introduced
to the cultural houses.
Miraculously, under your
leadership in terms of that era,
they're 50 years old too.
No one would ever even imagine
that they are 50 years
old Women Studies program.
I think that was enormously innovative
to have those programs at that time,
even though we were
reaching for a diversity.
So let me just focus on
the Afro-American house.
As you well know, that
was not done without pain.
You made the point that
they were brilliant men
initially that came, scholars themselves,
that pushed the university
for the vitality and the importance
of understanding African-American history.
I love Yale for the fact
that I think history
was really a theme that
ran throughout studies.
Dr. Louis Gates is a
product of Yale University.
We should never, he happens
to be a man, forgive me,
but he was very respectful of
women students at the time.
But the point is is that we should never
shy away from being more
superior than Princeton
on this experiment. (chuckles)
Anybody went to grad school, that's okay.
We should never shy away
for what we went through.
And I'll just threw a personal anecdote,
then I will just post a question,
so I'll move quickly as possible.
There was a question earlier today
about how you compare 1969 in
terms of change to now 2019.
So forgive me, my classmates,
this happens to also
be the year of return.
This is 400 years for
enslaved Africans who arrived
in New England in 1619.
What an interesting time
to come and do all these
historical things at that time.
But we became the mother
of African-American
Studies programs across America.
This is, we're not celebrating that now,
but I'm just trying to put together
all the historic, I think moments, Sam,
that we were going through if I'm correct.
And just this year, I took
up something that people
would initially respond to as
what is a member of congress
engaged in this kind of debate,
and that is of course the
H.R.40 is a commission
to study reparations proposals.
And my goal was to reflect
on where I came from,
but also Yale's pioneering
spirit about history.
And so I view this
commission as an attempt,
it hasn't been passed yet,
but it's going further
than it's ever gone,
leadership of the house,
and members of Congress
from all over the nation co-sponsoring it,
but the point is is that it's
about racial reconciliation
and then ultimately what do you do
in that period of history.
My question for you as
you laid the groundwork
for many of these folks,
Blassingame, if you remember,
you brought him--
- John Blassingame.
- [Congresswoman] You brought him here.
He was considered a genius
in terms of building that departments,
boom, that surely highlighted.
What do you view mixing women with that?
How do you view that as a significant
part of the leadership,
this whole cultural revolution
of acknowledging Asians,
Hispanics, Latinos,
African-Americans women,
all groups that adhere
to for been left out
and we unseeingly in that period of time
were acknowledging all of them.
I hope I left everybody, got everybody in,
the Women Studies program.
Did you all talk about that significance?
Did they Yale Corporation board?
Did they, were they impressed?
Did they know what you did? (laughs)
- Maybe not which was all for good.
- [Congresswoman] And I
sit down on this note.
Do they know that you kept
New Haven from imploding
in May of '79 when Kingman shut down
the university and said,
"Everybody, go out of class."
I remember when, that was not in '69,
it was '70, May Day,
'70, the spring of '70,
when they led us out, as they said,
'cause I remember in July
sort of digging myself in
to get those papers in that
we didn't get in at that time.
But I mean, all of that
was what women hear,
and I wanna say to the women who are here,
you are part of keeping the lid on.
You really were.
I think you were, most of
you were involved in this,
and you kept the lid
on while we were really
in one of the most explosive
historical moments,
and hysterical moments of history.
And we had all these different groups
because the African-American
students were hold up
at one of the secret society.
Somebody else was somewhere else.
Other people were hanging out in commons.
We all had our spaces,
but we all seem to know
that the administration
respected our dignity.
And were going to stand
with us on that dignity.
Otherwise, this place could have,
I won't finish the
sentence, but, I yield back,
as they say on the floor of the house.
- I yield back.
- [Congresswoman] Do they
know the significance of it?
I guess that's my question.
- Let me try and answer
couple of questions
that are so embedded there.
First of all, the Yale
trustees of Yale Corporation
at that time was incredibly supportive.
Some of you will remember
the meetings in the rink,
7,000 people in the
rink to argue over ROTC
or whatever it was we were arguing over.
And when we had one of those meetings,
we call the members of the corporation,
and I would say of the 16 members,
aside from the president, 14
were there for every event
and sat in the rink and participated.
They didn't speak, I don't
think, but they were there.
So they were very supportive.
We also had three, four,
great Afro-American trustees
at the time, three were women,
Marian Wright Edelman,
Eleanor Holmes Norton,
and Barbara Preiskel.
And then Judge Leon Higginbotham
of the Federal Court was also.
And those people gave us
guidance and understanding
that we might never otherwise have had.
Secondly, about the
cultural houses.
Some, I don't remember
how we learned it, but
we knew that no matter how many initial,
let's say Black students we admitted,
they had to have a place
of, a sense of safety
and getting together and so on.
And so the idea of the cultural house
seem to us to be almost
the number one thing
that ought to be done.
With regard to the
Afro-American studies major,
the great heroes of this
were a Black student
named Robbie Robinson and
Charles Taylor the provost.
And Charlie who was provost and therefore
he had a lot of things to do,
undertook to personally
develop with Robbie,
who was a senior and
there were other students
on the committee, I've
forgotten all their names,
but to undertake the
development of that major
with the faculty and I
think everybody understood
that in addition to needing a place
where a small group of people
could feel comfortable,
you needed an intellectual place
in which they could also feel comfortable.
And so the development of the
Afro-American studies major
was to us of the highest priority.
- Fascinating.
Questions, yes, lady in the blue?
- [Judith] We've been talking a lot
about the arrival of women in 1969.
- I'm sorry, the what?
- [Judith] Sorry, Judith Fekyoni,
1973, and Berkeley College.
We've been talking a lot
about the arrival of women
at Yale and I was
wondering if you could talk
a little bit about the first
years of women on campus
as part of Yale College
and particularly the belief
that I had always had
but maybe it's not true,
maybe it's imaginary, that
we were called the experiment
in coeducation for the
entire time that I was here.
- Is Ann here, Ann Perkins?
Ann's, I guess she's not here.
If you have not read Ann's book,
you absolutely must read it.
She has written a PhD dissertation
which is transformed into
a very good history book,
which documents the first two
years of coeducation at Yale.
And I can't make it any better.
I will say about it a couple of things.
One is that
I think without Elga, we
would've had a really tough time
because I think she was
our spiritual leader
as well as our administrative leader.
And I think she was the one
who kept the fires burning
in those first two years and kept the fire
underneath our behinds
which was important.
What was the second part?
- Experiment.
- Oh, the experiment.
Yeah, I don't know where that came from.
It was not, we were not gonna back off,
so there was never an intention at this
where we try it out and see if
it worked and then deciding.
I don't know where that came from
except I think it may have come as a,
from someone who was unhappy
that we weren't admitting
more women and therefore use this
as kind of a derogatory comment.
But there was never any
intention of backing off
and going back at all.
- Is someone raising
their hand way back there?
Yes.
- [Bliswilliams] I'm curious,
Bliswilliams Brown, Davenport '71.
I'm curious whether the administration
ever did anything to prepare
the men for our arrival?
(audience laughing)
- Great question.
- I'm gonna take the liberty of,
before I answer your question.
Somebody today in the afternoon seminar
said something that I have,
think is incredibly important.
We need to teach men about themselves.
We need a mandatory course for Yale males.
Because the masculinity
of Yale is not yet gone.
It's still very much a
part of the institution.
Now, over to your question.
Absolutely nothing.
(audience laughing)
And I mean it, nothing was done.
I'm not sure but what,
the word groups of men
who were, who wanted to be
hospitable, and they, I think,
an individual colleges
and individual groups,
there were things that happened where men
tried to be welcoming and
friendly and stuff like that.
There is some disagreement, say,
between John Wilkinson and myself.
I think there were more undergraduate men
who are against coeducation than he does.
I think there were a fair number,
I would think maybe 50% of the men who,
it wasn't like they didn't
like women or something,
it was just that they
thought Yale should be male.
So I, but we didn't do
anything to educate the men.
- Right there.
Let's get the microphone.
It's coming your way.
- Right behind you.
- [Glen] Speaking, Glen
Murphy, Calhoon '71.
Speaking as a male who was at Yale
during both before and
after the coeducation
I would remind you that coed week
was instigated by the male
undergraduate population.
- Avi Soyfer.
And we managed to accommodate 750 women
without the world spinning off its axis.
So I think it's fair to say
that the male undergraduate
population, not in its entirety,
but was out ahead of you as far
as coeducation was concerned
and didn't need any
institutional preparation
to make it happen.
- Let me, I'm gonna, I'm gonna
pick a fight with you, okay?
- Uh-oh.
- I don't think that's
what the question she was talking about.
You're absolutely right.
Avi Soyfer did a fabulous job
of putting together coeducation week
and like four or 500 women came
to Yale and spent the week,
went to classes, lived in
the dorms, and everything.
But I think the question
is a different question.
And that is that this institution,
since 1701 until 1969, was all male,
and it developed an atmosphere and a ethos
which is embedded in every
wall and every ceiling
and every floor of the institution.
Everyone says, and I'm
a fan of Morris today,
but everyone says Morris
is, they take women in,
they have all these
nice parties and so on.
You just go into the first
floor and find me a woman,
a picture of a woman.
There's no picture of any
woman on the first floor.
They're on the stairways,
they're up a stairs, they're hidden.
Now I don't wanna pick on Morris.
But I firmly believe,
because I got so passionate
about admitting women to Yale,
I have spent my time
thinking about this subject.
I have five or six undergraduate
advisees every year,
I got about 20 in college now,
half of them roughly are women.
They tell me that they feel that Yale
is still a masculine institution.
Now they're not scared,
they're not afraid,
they're going about their business.
But I think men have to
learn about masculinity.
Here we have Women Studies.
We don't have Men Studies.
You laugh, but listen.
Men are not so good at understanding
when they get together as a group,
how at a place like Yale,
how offensive they can be.
(audience laughing)
So I know what you're talking about.
And I agree that that coed
week was a great thing.
But I think if, I hate to tell
the president what to think about it.
I do believe that if we wanna
be really coeducational,
one of the things we have
to do is to teach men
to understand what being masculine is
and how it affects the other sex.
Ending that.
(audience applauding)
- Very interesting.
I think, am I getting the signal?
I think we have time.
Yes, right here.
- Hi, I'm Jen Castello.
- Don't get mad at me.
- [Jen] Brandford, class of 1972.
Like many of you, I'm sure, I
have been in alumni school's
volunteer interviewer for many years,
and I've been told by high
school students applying
that Yale is well known
now as the gay-friendly Ivy
when people were talking
about the cultural houses,
it brought back memories
when I was here as a student,
and volunteered for Dwight Hall.
And there was a homosexuality
discussion group
that gradually changed its
name openly to Gays at Yale.
When we talk about bringing
women to a men's school,
I remember there was some discussion
about this was a good thing
because it would make sure
that there were heterosexual
manly men at Yale.
And having close friends who
were gay men at the time,
although I didn't have
a close women friend
who identified as gay or
lesbian, I'm sure there are,
it was still sort of
not a manly thing to do.
The other thing is that I
won an award as a junior
and the kelt for the qualities
that the award was named for
and one of them was manliness.
(audience laughing)
And I used this a lot in
law school applications,
that like, okay, not
only was I good student,
but I was manly.
It's always raised this question for me,
was we know Yale is the mother of men
and you'd swim naked in the pool
and you'd lunch with the
other guys at Morris,
and there was a reinforcement
of a particular kind
of masculinity, but it was a
masculinity that presumably
was quite fearful of being
perceived as feminine in any way.
So I'm wondering now at what
point the change in Yale
became such that it is
perceived as a friendly Ivy
for gay, lesbian, queer,
binary, transgender,
the whole new area of gender.
Back when we were going to
Yale, it was only man or woman,
but now there's gender
and gender identity.
And if we're talking about how
you identify yourself
as a person, masculine,
still masculine environment like this,
I think that'd be a really interesting
area to discuss and to explore.
Going back in time to
1969, did this come up
in discussion that we
wanted the kind of men
we wanted Yale to admit were
manly, heterosexual men,
and we would bring in women
to make that possible?
Or did nobody even talk about it?
- No, in 1969, that subject
wouldn't have come up
because those kinds of subjects
didn't come up ever in 1969.
But I will say this, and
I'm not, I'm retired,
I'm not an administrator now.
But I will say this based on
my advisees and other students I know.
I marvel at how different
the world is today
and the view of undergraduates
today about sexual issues.
It is, it's a totally different world
than the world I was brought
up in and maybe some of you,
I don't know, I'm a
lot older than you are.
But there's no question that
these, all these issues,
I don't know whether
Yale's more gay-friendly
or any other friendly than
any other institution.
I just don't know whether
there's statistics
that would bare that out or not.
But I do know that the
issue of sexual identity
or sexual orientation
or something like that
is really a kind of not high
on people's agenda in meeting each other.
I mean, they may be
interested in the subject
of sexual identity,
and wanna talk about it
in a class or in a discussion group.
But there are students at Yale
who are friends of students who
have other sexual identities
than they do and they
just all get along fine.
So to me, that's an
issue that us oldtimers
have to learn to deal with.
- This will be the last question,
and it's the lady also in blue, gray.
Yes, you.
(audience laughing)
- Thank you.
Hi, I'm Jena Weiss, class of '73.
Earlier, you said you had a
disagreement with Jay Gitland
about when the old Yale
became the new Yale.
And you gave us your answer.
I'm curious about what his answer was, is.
- I wish Jay were here
and could defend himself.
I think Jay is undecided.
I think he thinks I'm wrong,
but I don't think he knows
where he actually thinks the
old Yale became the new Yale.
And I'm not sure actually
whether he thinks
it has become the new Yale.
So he may be, as an historian,
he may see this more on
a kind of gradual level
of moving forward, whereas
I see this particular era
as very abrupt, very
different, very changing.
But I'm reluctant to give
you a particular time.
He also was interested in
the period of when Yale
moved from being a seminary, if you will,
that is training people
to go into the ministry,
and it had its first
non-clerical president or rector.
But I don't think he ever
has given me a specific date
or time that he went along with.
So I feel badly I can't
answer it, but I really can't.
- So please join me in
thanking Sam Chauncey.
That was fabulous.
- Thank you, Marta.
- I mean really fabulous.
(audience applauding)